Okay, so this is the mark, right?
Is "Baby, It's Cold Outside" a date rape anthem?
Certain critics say "yes."
According to Snopes, the song
legitimizes sexual entrapment.
To avoid controversy, multiple
radio stations pulled it from holiday playlists.
For the record, the 74 year-old song is a
duet between a seemingly reluctant female
and a persistent suitor. It's old-fashioned
and that's part of its charm.
To say that it's about rape
is nearly as absurd as claiming that it
sends the wrong message on global
warming. The song is about love and
mutual attraction. The two characters are
toying with one another — matching wits,
having fun. Dropping the song has proved
to be a PR nightmare for radio stations.
Many have deemed it an act of censorship.
A poll in Denver is typical: 95% of respondents
want it back on the air. So the stations are
now busy restoring this much-loved duet
to the Christmas rotation, and several
versions of the song are surging in sales.
Civilization fought back and won.
What do you think about "Baby, It's Cold Outside"?
Should it be pulled from the airwaves?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.